let's get to some other world news now
when Facebook's parent company meta has
announced it will be sacking more than
11
000 employees that's around 13 of a
reduction in its Workforce CEO Mark
Zuckerberg says he hired more staff
during the pandemic but Revenue has now
slowed down the company has extended a
hiring freeze for more on this let's
speak to Chris stockle Walker in
Newcastle in the UK he's a technology
journalist and author Chris thanks so
much for being on this NewsHour firstly
what's your reaction to this news
particularly in the wake of Twitter's
sackings last week
yeah and he's incredibly unfortunate
news and I think indicates just how much
struggle there is for tech companies
right now to retain and keep staff at a
time when things are really really tough
for them obviously matters layoffs 11
000 people uh dwarfs twitters although
when you look at the actual proportion
of the company this is something like 13
of the organization it's almost 90 000
people that matter employees worldwide
but we we have indications that you know
some of these Cuts will come in
recruiting in other different areas and
largely it seems because Mark Zuckerberg
the founder and CEO of meta says due to
the pandemic and and changing priorities
which is a huge shift for this but
obviously big for the tech company in
the big sex sector in the world
Chris for years meta has been a
Powerhouse company what do these layoffs
indicate about the state of the company
and particularly given its stock has
dropped more than 72 percent this year
yeah I think it shows the sort of
stagnation of sorts with matter we know
that they made their name off the back
of social media obviously lots of us can
use the company in its previous guys as
Facebook have also owned Instagram and
also WhatsApp to key communication tools
that we use day in day out but really
matter Facebook in general has has kind
of been installing for a while Facebook
the app the the service and the website
hasn't seen that many users joining it
ever since uh pretty much the last five
or ten years it's kind of got a
reputation now as being very very uncool
and in its place Mark Zuckerberg is I
suppose trying to find a future for the
company that most people disagree with
which is this all-out pursuit of the
metaverse it's why they renamed their
company in recent years to try and
better represent I suppose what they
want it to be but for most people they
don't really seem to want to live in the
metaverse and it was okay kind of
acknowledged that this is the new
direction for the company and like it or
lump it you have to take it yes I wanted
to talk to you about metaverse firstly I
think you'll need to explain to me and
the rest of the audience what that
actually means but will those sort of
investment in this virtual reality type
technology all being vain do you think
yeah but let's say let's take the latter
first yes I think so because I think
most people don't like the idea of the
metaphors and partly because of what's
involved with it which is helpful for us
to explain that so you have to slap on a
pair of virtual reality goggles which
costs an awful lot of money some of them
more than a thousand dollars you then
have to plug yourself into a computer
you have to create a virtual
representation of yourself which takes
time and effort and then go around an
environment a graphical environment that
doesn't look as good as the real world
at the minutes and I think that's one of
the many reasons why matter is really
going to struggle because ultimately
people don't want to have to go through
hassle for an inferior version of
reality which is what at present The
Meta verse plans to be in it's worth
thinking that this is a huge bet for
author Mark Zuckerberg he is essentially
staking the future of his company on
this and because in large part of that
11 000 people now have lost their jobs
really appreciate your thoughts and your
analysis as always Chris stockhold
Walker a technology journalist and
author thank you so much